You know, Chris got hit,
you know, in the knees
yesterday, which is a play that
I think they ought to
take out of the game of football
from a receiver
standpoint. You know, I kind of
talked to the PA about it for
a while about,
you know, and I'd like to speak
to the rules competition
committee at some point. This
offseason to, I've seen that
hit too many times where a
defenseless
pass, catcher is in the process
of catching the ball and
he's hit by the defender. And
you know, a lot of the Defenders
would say
Well, we can't hit him in the
head anymore.
Well, the point is you can't hit
anyone in the head anymore.
You can't hit anyone in these
anymore except for receivers
because you can still hit them
in these which doesn't make any
sense to me.
You can't hit a defensive
lineman in these.
You can't hit a punter in the
knees. You can hit
a quarterback attorneys. You
can't hit a DB in the knees
except Were Somehow allowing
hits on
defenseless receivers in these.
So,
you know, it needs to be
addressed
and it needs to be really
thought out. It really is.
Hacks guys, careers and Chris,
you know, I know he'll overcome
it. It's so it's a tough rehab.
But, you know, you you tear
your ACL. That's that's a
lifelong injury,
you know, and I'm sure
almost every pass catcher in the
NFL would prefer
hit to the head over hit to the
knees.
I certainly would I take that,
you know million out of
a million.
It's amazing, man. Tom said,
basically everything that
I said the other day and my
whole thing was protect your
brother.
You know, I'm saying, protect
your brother. You got to
understand. I like, PJ weird.
Excuse me. I like, PJ Williams
when I called him out. It wasn't
because the hit was
dirty necessarily dirty. Okay,
it was a clean, hit by NFL
standards, but to me, it was a
dirty hit because PJ Williams,
he's a very smart guy. He's
played all the positions in
the secondary. He's a very
Versatile guys, so he's a very
smart guy when he hit
Godwin on the knees. He
immediately got up and
celebrated, he didn't. So he
intentionally, he wanted to hit
him at his knees. And all I'm
saying is look man. We're all
trying to make a
living. Why would you hit him up
there? You ask
any player in any sport female
male in any sport. Would you
rather get hit in the knee? Or
would you rather get hit in the
shoulder? They're going to 100
out of 100 times. They're going
to say hit me up in the upper
body because now I have A
chance to get up and walk away.
I get a chance to get up and
literally walk away. But when
you go at somebody's knees and
Tom is 100% spot on you don't go
at their knees because we
are brothers.
I can't take away your
opportunity
to make millions and millions of
dollars on a check this out.
Chris Godwin signed a one year
15 million dollar deal. One
year 15 million dollar deal. He
could have he gone a many other
places, got 50, 60 million
dollars, or 40 million, dollars
guaranteed, and and secured the
bag.
He sacrificed. For that
situation. And now all of
a sudden,
what team is going to go and pay
Chris Godwin for years, 60
million in guaranteed 40 million
because he's coming off
the ACL injury. So what he's got
to do, he's got to sign
another one year deal. Go
through an entire season
17 weeks, 18 weeks, plus
playoffs and see if he can stay
healthy to go get his money. So
that's why I tell players all
the time. These teams have
money. They're very, very
wealthy. You got to secure the
bag, always get your money.
Don't sacrifice for anybody.
Well, I completely agree. So let
me start there and and
something that's that off. From
what Tom said was that receiver
is the only position that we let
hits like this occur
through that resonated with me,
right? You can't do it to
a quarterback, that's completely
out of the game. You can't do
it. So defensive line that's
complete out of game, can't do
it. Offensive line that's
completely out of the game. So
you can't do it, then anybody
else. Now, how the hell are you
going to look at me and say
that a receiver, can't do it to
a kicker after a kick. How
the hell are you going to look
at me and say
that, a receiver
who's catching the ball with his
head, turned running full
speed and getting hit. A place
that he doesn't even know his
coming. That that could be a
legal hit. It just makes no
sense. And
to hear Tom go a million out of
a million. I would take
the high, hit over the low hit.
Well, why are we talking to
the players? Then before making
this Rule and this has been one
that hasn't made sense to me for
a long time. We've seen
Gronk, take
these shots. I thought Gronk
after the first hit, we both
thought this Rod that he was
looking a little tentative out
there
after that, massive shot.
And let's be clear. I mean, this
was a game where New
Orleans came in and from the
opening whistle was Is the more
physical team they were
physically. Just pushing around
Tampa in their own stadium in
every single way,
but I will say that I thought
that PJ Williams shot low.
It changed Gronk, it changed
some of those weapons. I just
thought it looked like Tampa was
playing tentative from then
on out.
Absolutely. It was spot-on. I
mean you look at Gronk Grant
like Grant when you've had
injuries to your knee, you
think about that. He said, oh my
God, I don't want to go
across the middle know, send me
out to them, you know, to
the sideline.
I don't want to come across the
middle. It changed the very
nature of the game because you
saw even Tyler Johnson. He was
in the game. He went across the
middle. He's peeking and
looking and I'm like, it just
me. We you and I we talked
about it, completely change the,
you know, the nature of
the game. I do think that They
will go back and look at that
as we take a look at some of
gronk's plays and he just
always looks sort of half speed
and anytime they would take
a close shot of his face. He
just looked nervous that
dropping balls. He's looking,
he's looking up for the head
before. He's even making
the catch. And he had the
biggest drop in the night on
that deep
one late in the game where he
just never even saw it. He was
white. Brady,
put the perfect throw down the
sideline and he just didn't
look up to see it right there,
right there, it was.
Yeah. For Ned told me that Rob
Gronkowski is the guy that
brings all the energy to this
team. And he didn't have any
energy. We're looking at like
Rob is normally a lot more, you
know, active and excited.
He just kind of out there. He
looked tired. He looked like he
was out of shape. I'm like
what's going on with Rob
Gronkowski, but that hit really
set the tone
and it wasn't the only hit,
right? I mean, I can remember
a handful of other bigots. Even
the one where fournette got
spun around and he spun him and
a full 360. And for that leaves
the game.
I mean, they came in there and
they just pushed him around.